[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette émission spéciale consacrée
au premier tour des élections
législatives
nous sommes le lundi 13 juin voici les
titres
le taux de participation aux élections
législatives en baisse dans les yvelines
par rapport à 2010 7 48 13 % des
yvelinois ne se sont pas rendus aux
urnes ce week end où se situe le
département par rapport à la moyenne
nationale point complet dans ce journal
a des beaux scores dans le département
pour ensemble et la nuque baisse pour le
deuxième tour des législatives la
coalition présidentielle a réussi à
qualifier ces douze candidats la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale sera quant à elle présente dans
11 circonscriptions sur 12 et puis
nouveau coup dur pour la droite
yvelinoise aucun candidat de la
formation politique ne sera au second
tour les deux députés sortants arrivent
en troisième position il ne briguera pas
un autre mandat une surprise pour ce
département ancré traditionnellement à
droite
et nous parlerons également des duels à
céret à suivre au second tour et puis au
reste on en parlera également du
rassemblement national qui s'est
qualifié dans la 9e circonscription
mais avant de débuter ce journal un
point sur les candidats donc qualifiés
au second tour de ces élections est
législatives tout de suite les résultats
dans les yvelines circonscription par
circonscription
[Musique]
on
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et avec nous ce soir pour parler de ce
premier tour des élections législatives
rappelle mata duvignau bonsoir je suis
en justice
maître de conférences en droit public
allure et sql vous serez avec nous
pendant toute la durée de l'émission ce
soir on reviendra sur ce scrutin plus
précisément par thématiques tout à
l'heure mais je vais déjà vous demander
votre sentiment global sur ce premier
tour
j'ai le sentiment global c'est un échec
en échec de la démocratie mesure où on
l'a bien constaté l'absorption et
abstention record à 50% c'est un
véritable échec et quel que soit le
vainqueur de la semaine prochaine que ce
soit en paix sous ensemble aucun des
deux parties aucune des deux conditions
ne pourra se revendiquer d'un véritable
mandat populaire et donc c'est un
véritable coup
un coup d'arrêt mais véritablement
quelque chose de nous à réfléchir dans
mon super démocratique
vous en avez déjà un peu parlé en de
l'abstention je vous propose justement
de faire le point sur ce taux
d'abstention de ce scrutin donc de
dimanche qu'elle a été la participation
et des idées noires vous en avez déjà un
peu parlé c'est bien 400 go journalistes
portés sont 18 vous êtes là avec nous
pour faire le point bonsoir bonsoir donc
est-ce que déjà vous pouvez nous
éclairer est ce qu'ils se sont mobilisés
les yvelinois pour ce premier tour eh
bien on va commencer par un chiffre
significatif
ce chiffre c'est
48,13 % c'est le taux d'abstention et
des élections législatives pour ce
premier tour en légère hausse par
rapport à 2010 est il était de 47,80 de
42% par rapport au chiffre national les
yvelinois sont de meilleurs élèves le
département des yvelines est
généralement au dessus de la moyenne
nationale puisqu'il atteint un taux
record pour un premier tour depuis 1958
avec
52,49 % alors hier soir on a interrogé
des candidats qui ont réagi au score de
leurs diverses circonscriptions les
élections législatives par si déjà il ya
peu de gens qui vont voter et nous c'est
vrai qu'on a essayé de jouer sur une
campagne vraiment pour les jeunes
notamment de les investir et c'est vrai
que malheureusement les jeunes se sont
beaucoup abstenus notre circonscription
a voté un petit peu plus que la moyenne
nationale donc ça c'est bien on va
essayer d'encourager les gens quand même
à se déplacer à voter encore la semaine
prochaine parce que c'est ce que je
crains le plus pour la semaine prochaine
parce que les gens qui n'ont plus leurs
candidats au deuxième tour des fois
staps tiennent plutôt que de voter j'ai
lu locale vous savez quand on essaye de
se donner on essaye de de faire beaucoup
pour nos territoires on a cette passion
des territoires est effectivement de
voir qu'il ya autant d'abstention c'est
aussi une marque de désintérêt des
français de la politique et je trouve ça
bien dommage
alors on le voit est lésé lieu ne
comprennent pas pourquoi les électeurs
ne votent plus le taux d'abstention et
ne cesse d'augmenter et même ces
élections législatives 2022 n'ont pas
réussi à faire rêver certains les élus
eux disent que la campagne n'a pas
décollé raphaël mata e duvignau à
pourquoi les élections législatives
depuis quelques années ne passionne plus
alors c'était pas simple ce ne sont pas
simplement les actions initiative c'est
de manière générale les élections nous
passionnons plusieurs raisons la
première raison c'est que l'homme
politique ne correspond pas ou ne
correspond plus aux aspirations des
citoyens à cette un premier et un
deuxième élément c'est qu'il ya sur
seront construits réels ou imaginés ou
fantasmée du fait que le personnel
politique est plus ou moins corrompus
cet élitisme
bref il ya une défiance envers le parti
politique il ya une crise bien s'y pique
entre la population les citoyens d'un
côté et le personnel politique de
l'autre et donc finalement rien ne se
retrouvent plus alors que c'est
essentiel ne se retrouvent plus dans le
personnel politique ensuite il ya une
sorte de wii les gens sont désabusés
finalement il considère que le personnes
politiques quels qu'ils soient ne
répondra pas leurs aspirations de
répondre à leurs attentes
effectivement il ya aussi le fait de pub
quinquennat que les élections
législatives viennent juste après les
présidentielles et que tout s'est joué
lors de l'élection présentielle élection
majeure en france et que au final ça
sert à rien là je le dis très simplement
ça ne sert à rien d'aller voter aux
législatives puisque un président élu
avec une et laura manif mécaniquement
une majorité dont ça ça peut expliquer
aussi ce désintérêt
l'abstention touche aussi davantage les
jeunes et les catégories populaires si
l'on prend par circonscription dans la
huitième l'abstention atteint 58,2 75%
et si on prend la ville de
mantes-la-jolie plus de 63% des
électeurs ne se sont pas déplacés alors
direction la 9e circonscription avec un
taux d'abstention de
52,94 % parmi les communes de ce
territoire ou dans guerville bonnières
sur seine ou encore les mureaux les
mureaux avec un taux record aussi
environ 70% de taux d'abstention alors
deux autres circonscriptions dépasse la
barre des 50% de taux d'abstention la
septième et la 11e et on va finir quand
même sur des villes qui se sont
mobilisés maisons laffitte le chesnay
rocancourt le ministre denis le vésinet
est le chef le chef lieu du département
versailles merci beaucoup s'est dit
agathe son goût pour ces informations
journalistes pour tv 78 alors vous
l'avez vous l'avez dit un rappel matin
de vignes où le taux d'abstention c'est
un peu le point noir pour toutes les
élections finalement vous le disiez même
si les candidats certains candidats sont
donc au deuxième tour ce n'est pas
forcément une victoire pour eux
également
non
quelques alors on ne peut pas présager
de ce qui va se passer au togo peut-être
qu'il y aura un kiosque au petit
ouailles un cours nous le dira mais en
tout état de cause une abstention de
ceux de ce
cet auteur est vraiment jeune âge
insista j'ai l'impression de radoter
mais j'insiste vraiment est
catastrophique pour la démocratie parce
qu'on ne peut pas d'un côté dire les
personnes politiques ne fait rien on n'a
pas confiance et de l'autre côté ne pas
aller voter quelle que soit son opinion
il faut aller voter pour pouvoir
justement avoir un moyen de pression sur
une piste hurle sur la manière dont le
pays sera gouverné dans durant les cinq
prochaines années passées à promouvoir
un deuxième élément c'est que
effectivement lancement prochaine quels
que soient nos partis qui aura le plus
de voix je ne parle même pas de majorité
mais le parti qui aura le plus de voix
ne pourra pas s'enorgueillir d'un
soutien populaire massif
quand on voit là j'ai fait mes petits
calculs pas s'ils sont grandes mais
quand on vole une baisse est ensemble
qui sont quasiment à égalité aujourd'hui
il représente à peine chacun 12 % du
corps électoral en termes de légitimité
ont fait mieux et donc quel que soit le
vainqueur il sera peut-être le vainqueur
moral mais est le vainqueur dans les
chiffres mais en réalité politiquement
c'est un échec pour les deux parties et
donc comment faire finalement pour
intéresser de nouveau ses électeurs
pour intéresser ses électeurs il
faudrait et c'est que j'avais dit le
landais débat sur les élections
présidentielles il faudrait à mon avis
rénover le système institutionnel et
probablement insuffler un dose de
proportionnelle pour l'élection du
possible alors pour cette année c'est
raté ces experts mais éventuellement une
réforme constitutionnelle permettrait
permettant pardon d'instaurer une dose
de proportionnelle pas fortement une
proportionnelle intégrale mais une dose
de proportionnelle mais lente que ta
majorité à scrutin proportionnel
permettront déjà une meilleure
représentativité des forces politiques
ce qui permettrait un meilleur débat
démocratique et avec la nécessité pour
le parti majoritaire 2 - coalition
d'aller négocier de chercher des
compromis et finalement de se retrouver
sur un dénominateur commun sur des
éléments essentiels afin de le faire
avance ni le pays voilà ça c'est un
aimant institutionnels d'autre élément
serait de trouver des mécanismes
permettant au parlement de renforcer ses
pouvoirs de renforcer son contrôle sur
l'action du gouvernement sur l'action du
président de la république et pourquoi
pas certains de mes collègues me disent
également
faire en sorte que mes élections
présidentielle et législatives ai je eu
lieu le même jour est donc dans ce cas
là on renforcerait le parlement et ça
permettrait peut-être de redynamiser de
redynamiser la vie politique ce sont des
pistes on pourrait en changer l'autre
mais voilà ce sont les pistes
alors je propose de faire un tour du
côté à des résultats dans les îles une
ensemble le parti de la majorité
présidentielle a réussi à qualifier ces
douze candidats au deuxième tour des
législatives si certains sont largement
favoris pour la victoire d'autres vont
devoir batailler tout de même pour
remporter leur circonscription c'est
l'état des lieux avec michael et demi
d'euros regarder d'où sur 12 pour la
majorité présidentielle dans les
yvelines tous les candidats étiquetés
ensemble pour ces élections législatives
se sont qualifiés pour le second tour
certains sont largement en tête les
députés sortants jean noël barrot dans
la 2e arrivent premiers tout comme
béatrice piron dans la troisième
circonscription par rapport au résultat
je crois que je suis assez sereine on va
dire parce que je pense pas qu'ils aient
beaucoup de réserves de voix sur la
gauche et que je ne pense pas qu'un même
que les républicains où les gens de
reconquête irait voter quand même pour
malin brody donc je suis assez sereine
les autres favoris ont répondu présent
dans la 5e circonscription la députée
sortante et nouvelle ministre les outre
mériel brune privée largement en tête
face à la candidate nuxe dans la 12e
circonscription karl olive vire en tête
ce dimanche 12 juin avec une confortable
avance sur edwin le gris mais l'actuel
maire de poissy veut rester prudent on
mène bien la mi temps et tant mieux et
on va pas on va pas s'en excuser mais
moi qui suis compétiteur vous savez que
tant que les arbitres n'a pas donné le
coup de sifflet final rien n'est gagné
il faut rien mais estimé des candidats
devront en revanche batailler dans
plusieurs circonscriptions dans la
septième nadia et arrive en tête avec 29
points 55% des suffrages 2 points de
plus que son adversaire tout se jouera
ce dimanche dans la 8e edwige hervieux
devoir refaire son retard même tendance
dans la 11e aurait lié à pia senza aura
fort à faire face à williams martinez
candidats nous ce n'est au second tour
face à nu c'est maintenant notre
principal objectif c'est que tout
personne qui une fois de plus son
républicains sur un projet qui est
diamétralement opposée face à celui qui
a proposé par lannux on appelle à la
mobilisation de tous ces électeurs en
2017 la république en marche avait raflé
onze circonscriptions sur 12
pourront-ils faire aussi bien cinq ans
plus tard réponse ce dimanche 19 juin
pour connaître le résultat des urnes
alors rappelle matin du bignon vient de
le voir dans ce dans ce sujet douze
candidats sur douze qualifiés selon vous
est ce que finalement la majorité
présidentielle est amené à remplacer à
la droite yvelinoise
alors déjà soulignons tout un formidable
au score le pour le parti et présentiel
partie potentiel qu'on annonce n'est
vraiment colle aux critiques
commençaient à subir une déculottée de
la part de deux nuls donc vaut donc
c'est un certain c'est un bon score
ensuite effectivement je ne vais pas
faire de prédictions je ne dirai pas si
les candidats de la majorité seront tous
élus sachent que je suis incapable de
livres par contre effectivement on a
l'impression que le la majorité
présidentielle en tout cas dans les
yvelines a remplacé la droite ça c'est
clair les républicains puisque comme un
fait notable tous les candidats
républicains ont été éliminés et c'est
parfois sèchement donc effectivement on
peut parler d'un remplacement en tout
cas sur ces élections-là de la droite
par le
parti présidentiel
donc on a à nicolas d'ombré qui vient de
nous rejoindre en plateau bonsoir mais
celui-ci alors c'est la deuxième force
politique dans le département des
yvelines qui ressort de ce scrutin la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale sera présente donc elle dans
onze circonscriptions sur 12 ce sera
donc au second tour des élections
législatives 2022 et oui justin est en
fait c'est la conséquence des résultats
du premier tour des élections
législatives
vous savez un la gauche et parti uni
dans ce scrutin eh bien on va regarder
tout de suite les détails des résultats
van pelt premier tour
c'est l'un des deux candidats de la
nuque ps arrivé en tête au premier tour
des élections législatives
willem martin a obtenu 32% des suffrages
dans la 11e circonscription des yvelines
il devance la candidate de la majorité
présidentielle
aurélie pia senza avec 25% des voix nous
sommes donc largement en tête nous
sommes même en tête dans quatre villes
sur sept dans l'ensemble de la de la
circonscription avec d'excellents scores
à trappes à la verrière et même à
elancourt autres territoires où la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale et devant la majorité
présidentielle la 8e circonscription
benjamin lucas a récolté 33 % des
exprimés contre 24% des suffrages pour
edwige hervieux candidate du mouvement
ensemble il ya aujourd'hui une volonté
de faire barrage emmanuel macron de ne
pas subir une politique injuste et
brutal la retraite à 65 ans la baisse
continue du pouvoir d'achat et prix
augmenter les salaires qui stagnent et
puis de l'espoir parce que nous portons
un projet de justice sociale un projet
pour le pouvoir d'achat pour la dignité
pour le respect des citoyennes et des
citoyens avec l'union de ces mouvements
de la france un soumise au parti
socialiste en passant par le parti
communiste ou encore europe ecologie les
verts la gauche signe son retour dans
les yvelines sur les douze
circonscriptions aux candidats de la
nuque ps sont au second tour en annoncer
la gauche est à peine six mois comme
morte et en fait nous voilà au second
tour dans cinq circonscriptions y
compris la nôtre ici avec un score qui
est dans la moyenne nationale dans les
25 % on connaît la sociologie de notre
circonscription sait que ça va être
difficile vu justement cette sociologie
là mais si tous les abstentionnistes et
bien voté pour nous on peut a remporté
cette circonscription en relativisant
par rapport à la participation la gauche
redevient une force politique de premier
plan sur le territoire yvelinois en 2017
aucun candidat de gauche n'avait réussi
à accéder au second tour des élections
législatives
là on vient de le voir dans votre sujet
de circonscription roncq ont vu l année
parce arrivé en tête la 8e et la 11e
circonscription lé duel entre les
candidats de ces territoires risque
d'être serré effectivement justine et on
l'a vu dans la 11e circonscription des
yvelines williams martinez est en
ballottage favorable le candidat de
l'ani ps obtient deux mille voix de plus
qu aurélie pièce elsa face à la
candidate de la majorité présidentielle
la gauche a de la vence mais attention
au report des voix vous le savez les
républicains pourrait lui être favorable
la clé un pour la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale
finalement ce sera la participation et
on écoute williams martinez au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude et de julien
leroy la jeunesse les quartiers
populaires est en fait toutes celles et
tous ceux qui veulent tourner la page d'
emmanuel macron se sont mobilisés
massivement donc bonne nouvelle pour le
premier tour mais soyons très clairs
pour le second tour il faut passer un
cap supplémentaire tous ceux qui se
sentaient pas encore concernés par cette
élection maintenant qu'ils vont pouvoir
choisir entre emmanuel macron ou la
nouvelle union populaire maintenant il
faut qu'ils se déplacent il faut qu'ils
fassent le choix alors là vous aime
circonscription c'est cette commune
parmi ces communes il y attrape et où il
ya martinez a réalisé son plus gros
score sur la circonscription en
récoltant plus de 55% des voix et il ya
un potentiel électoral c'est à dire
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui se sont
pas déplacés à trappes l'abstention
atteint près de 63% et qu'en est il donc
concernant la 8e circonscription
eh bien c'est la même situation dans la
8e circonscription benjamins lucas
candidats de la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale a récolté près de
trois mille électeurs de plus que la
candidate de la majorité présidentielle
comme dans la 11e circonscription tout
dépendra du report des voix notamment
des électeurs du rassemblement national
arrivé en troisième position et des
républicains arrivé en quatrième
position et le candidat de la nuque est
content bien aussi aller les convaincre
ses électeurs de la droite on écoute
benjamins lucas c'est évidemment les
abstentionnistes mais je le dis aussi à
celles et ceux qui ont fait d'autres
choix moi je ferai en sorte de
travailler avec tout le monde y compris
avec ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord avec
moi à la question c'est est ce qu'on a
besoin d'un député aux ordres de macron
est ce qu'on a besoin d'un député libre
et qu'il descend ce territoire et cette
circonscription est ce que veulent ses
habitants pour le pouvoir d'achat les
services publics c'est ça le sujet et la
question c'est aussi un référendum sur
la retraite à 65 ans donc on aura des
surprises moi je vous le dis je pense
que les électrices et les électeurs que
que vous classé à droite mais qui
refusent la politique d' emmanuel macron
et pour conclure nicolas une autre
circonscription risquent elles d'être
serrée également oui ça va être serré
notamment dans la 7e circonscription
ries toi qu'on a dit un ancien ministre
délégué à la ville est candidate à l'âme
pour la majorité présidentielle
elle sera opposée à la représentante de
la nu ps michel christophoul et il faut
savoir qu'ici là c'était très serré au
premier tour il y avait mille voix
d'écart entre les deux candidates mais
c'est nadia qui était en tête alors pour
conclure finalement par rapport à ces
duels on l'a vu on a l'impression que ce
sera la participation qui sera décisive
les alors du coup raphaël mata duvignau
est-ce que vous pensez que ces candidats
justement de la nu peuvent passer au
second tour notamment s'ils arrivent à
mobiliser les abstentionnistes de leur
territoire
oui alors effectivement vous avez vous
avez parfaitement raison la clé du
scrutin tout cas pour les
circonscriptions dont on a parlé
seront à la fois la participation est
donc le taux d'abstention donc la
capacité de nuxe ou du ps à mobiliser
les abstentionnistes ça c'est un élément
important et j'ai envie de dire je ne
suis pas sûr parce que ou n'ont pas
réussi à mobiliser au premier tour pour
quelles raisons ils arriveraient à
mobiliser au second tour donc je là je
suis assez sceptique un autre élément
aussi n'y a pas en considération ces
lots on en parle partout qu'on en parle
partout c'est la réserve de bois est ce
que est ce que les candidats soutenus
par le par la nuit baisse ont une
réserve de voix ce n'est pas sûr quand
on voit les autres les autres partis d
autres chiffres des niveaux des
circonscriptions on voit que la réserve
de voix est assez faible
donc ça c'est un élément aussi à prendre
en considération est a contrario quand
on regarde les chiffres de les chiffres
de mort tremble on voit que bon les
électeurs républicains on peut supposer
je n'en sais rien mais on peut supposer
qu'elle appelait les électeurs
républicains iront probablement se
reportait sur un candidat de la majorité
présidentielle
donc en fait mécaniquement il est
possible que
un candidat de la majorité
présidentielle ne se passait devant
simplement avec le reste avec la réserve
de voix donc ça c'est un point important
est un autre point important c'était le
comportement des électeurs du
rassemblement national parce que j'ai
oublié de le dire tout à l'heure mais
malgré tout au niveau national ces
électeurs là représente depuis
maintenant un certain nombre d'années en
réalité s'est stabilisé entre 18 et 20%
et donc il faut compter avec notre force
là et les électeurs qui n'ont pas de
candidat finalement qualifié de bon tour
que vont ils faire et ce qu'ils vont
voter ni baisse ou est ce qu'ils vont
voter pour un candidat soutenu par
emmanuel macron je n'en sais rien c'est
assez c'est à ces évolutions se sera
volatile dans la vie donc voilà c'est si
c'est difficile
à prédire mais voilà la question c'est
vraiment la réserve de voix pour les
candidats du ps et la guerre d'août
merci beaucoup nicolas landry d'avoir
été avec nous en plateau journalistes
pour tv 78 ans raphaël mata duvignau
vous restez avec nous pendant cette
émission et on va parler à présent de la
droite qui elle n'aura pas de duel au
second tour c'est une désillusion pour
les républicains et l'union des
démocrates et indépendants aucun
candidat qualifié dans le département
ils arrivent tous en troisième voire
quatrième position je vous propose de
regarder ce récapitulatif de mathilde de
franck les élections législatives 2022
signe-t-elle la fin des républicains
dans les yvelines pour un département
qui vote traditionnellement à droite
aucun candidat n'est qualifié pour le
second tour ils arrivent tous au pied du
podium en 3e voire en quatrième position
pour certains très sincèrement je crois
que c'est une très grande déception que
nous pouvons
voir par rapport au résultat d'hier j'ai
pensé encore une fois pour connaître le
terrain pour être sur le terrain que nos
territoires et est encore restée à
droite moi j'ai vécu l'élection
départementale elle est dernière où la
droite était encore forte ça n'est pas
aujourd'hui ce qui ce qui pouvait être
quand on regarde on prendra le temps
d'analyser un petit peu les chiffres
qu'on a on a fait un bon score sur la
rassure la droite c'est vrai que ça a
été éparpillés avec un vote que moi je
n'attendais pas forcément aussi fort de
l'extrême droite à la fois reconquête
sur des vignes comme le chesnay ou
houleux et le fn ont enfin leur
assemblée nationale sur ville de tome
villepreux un jeu j'aurais qu'ils font
un très bon score qui est tout à fait
inhabituelle dans la 11e circonscription
le député sortant depuis 2020 philippe
benassaya et évincé l'ancien maire de
bois d'arcy fini en troisième position
avec 18% autre député sortant dans la 8e
circonscription michel vialay en 2017
c'est le seul républicain a accédé à
l'assemblée nationale 2022 renversement
de tendance michel vialay se retrouve en
quatrième position avec 7,85 % des voix
seulement c'est assez inquiétant parce
que quand vous voyez l'investissement
qu'a pu avoir philippe et la sai arles
ou même de meshuggah les autres
départements c'était quand même assez
calme incroyable parce que les autres
députés soient sincèrement on les voit
quand même très peu aussi on les a vu
très peu dans la première dans la
mandature précédente
autre bouleversement pour la droite dans
la première circonscription pour la
première fois depuis plus de 30 ans elle
n'est pas présente au second tour des
élections législatives
la dynamique nationale a pris le dessus
par rapport à l'ancrage local deuxième à
conflans derrière l'union de la gauche
et troisième au niveau de la
circonscription je ne serai pas au
second tour des élections législatives
les vagues nationale était trop forte et
ont pris le pas sur le local je tiens à
remercier les électeurs qui ont voté
pour moi après la défaite de la droite
aux présidentielles avec un score de
valérie pécresse à 4,78 % la désillusion
se poursuit aux législatives où elle
recueille 13 17% des voix alors appel
matin du bignon on vient de le voir dans
dans ce reportage on l'a vu dans les
résultats nationaux et c'est encore plus
parlant donc dont les yvelines le
département traditionnellement quand
même ancré à droite le parti républicain
n'a plus le vent en poupe pourquoi ce
déclin en si peu de temps finalement
alors plusieurs explications sont
possibles la première c'est
qu'effectivement ça a été tout un
reportage un jeu le résultat je suis
quasiment logiquement et mécaniquement
le résultat des présidentielles
j'ai envie de dresser un parallèle entre
les publics à l parti socialiste la
disparition progressive
inéluctable du ps a commencé en fait
lors de la précédente les deep nature
mais je pense que les républicains
suivent aujourd'hui ce même mouvement du
fait de commander de l'absorption par
emmanuel macron et sont partis deux des
principaux des principales idées
finalement des principales
problématiques tenue par la droite à
droite sociale à la droite gaulliste on
va dire qui est plutôt compatible avec
le sens historique finalement et de
l'autre côté on a le rassemblement
national qui est eric zemmour aussi
qu'ils n'excellent de de phagocyter un
certain nombre de questions les
questions identitaires de sécurité
l'immigration etc et donc moins roulant
la droite aujourd'hui souffre d'un
manque de ça a été dit dernièrement la
manque d'incarnation et donc la droite
aujourd'hui n'a plus de véritable
fabrique à l'est républicain non plus de
gouvernail il n'y a plus de boussole il
n'y a pas de véritable projet de projet
de société il n'y a pas de véritable
incarnation et donc au final malgré
l'action des acteurs locaux qui sont
reconnus et on le voit notamment avec
les résultats qui ce qui reste le
positif au niveau des municipales ils
étaient des régionales mais de manière
générale le parti des républicains
demain car ne plus de l'espoir alors je
dis pas que du ps et emmanuel macron
incarner l'espoir mais en tout cas ce
parti dit républicain aujourd'hui
souffre d'un vin d'un logiciel qui n'est
plus là le jour tout simplement et je
pense que c'est une raison pour
lesquelles les républicains aujourd'hui
son sont en voie non pas de disparition
c'est un gros c'est un grand mot en tout
quatre s'essouffle très très fortement
et le fait soit expulsé si vous venez
dans les yvelines est vraiment
caractéristique de ceux de ce phénomène
merci rappelle matin d'avignon on
accueille à présent bixente malien senti
cette vanne qui nous a rejoint sur le
plateau d'on soir % juste une vous êtes
là pour revenir sur les résultats de la
deuxième plus grande circonscription des
yvelines la 9e circonscription qui
occupe tout le nord-est du département
et vous allez nous expliquer pourquoi on
parle de cette circonscription oui
c'était important de revenir sur cette
circonscription justin puisque ici est
passé beaucoup de choses hier tout
d'abord c'est la seule des yvelines où
le rassemblement national s'est qualifié
pour le second tour ça c'est la
véritable information dimanche prochain
le député sortant bruno myle yens du
parti de la majorité présidentielle sera
opposé à laurent morin responsable
départemental du fn c'est la première
fois qu'un candidat est reine est au
second tour d'une élection législative
dans le département des iv ou l'écoutent
nous avons réussi au fur et à mesure par
je crois notre sérieux je crois aussi un
travail de terrain un travail
relationnel avec les différents acteurs
du territoire a montré que nous pouvions
représenter des candidatures
alternatives sérieuses et je crois que
ce résultat le concrétisent 32 communes
donc sur les 88 de la 9e circonscription
été remporté par laurent maurin beaucoup
de petits villages mais quand même neuf
municipalités de plus de mille votants à
bonnières-sur-seine et ft-romeu freneuse
notamment deux communes de plus de 4000
habitants il se place devant le candidat
nubes victor payack donc un résultat
plutôt satisfaisant là on l'a vu pour
pour l'endroit justement dans cette zone
qu'en est-il de nu ps c'est la
désillusion victoria qui termine
troisième et écoutez bien à seulement 88
voix de laurent maurin un résultat
frustrant forcément pour le jeune de 21
ans qui lui coûte sa place au second
tour on est forcément un peu déçu parce
que c'est vrai que j'ai avec mélenchon
sur la 9e circonscription des yvelines
avait fait un score assez impressionnant
notamment aux mureaux après il a vu
toute la journée ya pas eu beaucoup de
mobilisation il ya eu beaucoup
d'abstentions et ça c'était nationale
donc voilà on s'attendait un petit peu
avoir une perte par rapport au score de
jean luc mélenchon présidentielle ça
fait partie du vieux mais bon on est
quand même contents que le ps arrive au
troisième comme aux présidentielles avec
jean luc mélenchon la vague du ps à
déferler aux mureaux 40% des suffrages
exprimés mais c'est une donnée d'autant
plus frustrante au final pour victoria
qu'on lui qu'on le disait plutôt
seulement 30% des habitants se sont
rendus aux urnes et justement pour le
second tour le favori c'est le député
sortant bruno millet louis arrivé en
tête il part forcément favori mais le
second tour dépendra aussi du report des
voix vers le candidat soutenu par
emmanuel macron on peut supposer que
certains électeurs nubes pourrait voter
pour lui même situation pour les
républicains qui ont réuni 10 % des voix
avec pauline vinokourov le faire mais
attention néanmoins au rassemblement
national qui pourra compter sur
reconquête qui a fait 5 % sur ce
territoire en écoute bruno myle yens sur
ce second tour justement où deuxième
tour bien évidemment je vais essayer de
rassembler tous les républicains pour
faire front contre le rassemblement
national parce que je me suis battu
toute ma vie contre l'extrême droite et
c'est pas aujourd'hui je vais arrêter et
si on est un tant soit peu républicain
on craque on se doit d'aller voter le 19
et en dessous doit d'aller voter contre
le rassemblement national quoi qu'il en
soit le suspense reste entier dans une
circonscription classé parmi les mauvais
élèves dans le département en terme de
participation à presque cinq points de
la moyenne départementale qui elle est à
51% et justement m raphaël mata duvignau
pardon un petit mot sur cette
circonscription est la seule avec le
rassemblement national
oui effectivement c'est un ça fait
partie de
l'équipement de la daisy fille
maintenant c'est vrai qu'à quelques
dizaines de voix près on aurait pu avoir
un résultat s mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir hosties et ça
je me suis très c'est le résultat
finalement du candidat reconquête qui
n'y ait plus tu as quand même assez
intéressant pas intéressant à s'élever
finalement on va la nation que dans ce
cas là ça peut jouer en faveur du
candidat y aurait en toute logique un
millième réélu ça il n'y a aucun dribble
mais c'est intéressant de voir que dans
cette dans cette circonscription la
ferme le participation est plutôt
favorables finalement au
l'extrême droite à rennes plus plus
coquet
mais à priori il n'y a pas de jus pour
que le candidat sortant sera réélu en
tout cas merci beaucoup de chaînes
thématiques santé steban pour ces
informations journalistes pour tv 78 on
touche à la fin de ce journal peut-être
rappelle mathieu vignon un mot sur ce
qu'on peut attendre du second tour de
ces élections législatives alors on peut
attendre plusieurs choses si on peut
espérer un sursaut démocratique dans le
sens vu la participation serait
peut-être un petit peu plus élevé ça
c'est un premier élément est donc il
faut il faut les séries qu'on que soit
le bord politique deuxièmement ce qu'ils
font sinon on va attendre véritablement
c'est le fait de savoir alors toutes les
prédictions disque ensemble
à coeur bon je n'en sais rien mais ce
qu'il faut attendre c'est savoir si le
parti vainqueur aura simple une majorité
absolue c'est à 1989 minimum députés
pour avoir les coudées franches pour
mener la politique pour laquelle il a
été élu ça c'est un élément important
ou alors il n'y aura qu'une majorité
relative et dans ce cas là le parti qui
aura gagné des élections devra pas ce
que je disais tout à l'heure composer
avec les autres forces politiques pour
essayer de trouver des majorités de
circonstance des majorités
conjoncturelles ponctuelles pour tel ou
tel programme politique ou tel ou tel
projet et puis un plan d un élément qui
est très important aussi c'est le
comportement des autres partis les
républicains le rassemblement national
mais aussi on a envie de dire du parti
socialiste du parti communiste des
écologistes pas puisque rappelons le on
line ups n'est pas un parti c'est une
coalition est long à l'assemblée
nationale sauf changement drastique mais
à l'international chacun aura qu son
groupe politique et donc on va voir le
quantitativement la force de chaque
groupe politique pour pouvoir
éventuellement peser sur l'ensemble du
débat on pourrait très bien imaginer ça
je fais de la politique fiction pour un
cube maggi n'est par exemple le parti
socialiste avec un certain nombre de
députés plus de quinze former son groupe
politique et peut-être en cas de défaite
de gens que mélenchon ceux des salades
celui des slips l'accès de la presse est
libre sa vie de groupe politique
indépendant et donc ça peut être un
style et au tien intéressant à voir mais
évidemment on verra ça à dimanche que
les prochains ajustements on le rappelle
à date de second tour ce dimanche 19
juin merci beaucoup rappellent matin de
vigneault d'avoir été avec nous pendant
toute cette émission je le rappelle vous
êtes maître de conférences en droit
public à l'udf plus merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous avant de fermer ce
journal un point à nouveau sur le
résultat à des élections légistatives
puisque elle c'est la fin de cette
émission spéciale en tout cas merci à
tous de nous avoir suivi et puis on vous
laisse justement sur ses résultats dans
les épines circonscription par
circonscription très bonne soirée à tous
et à très vite sur tv 78
[Musique]
on
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
oh
on